"I'll pour this pestilence into his ear. So will I make the net that will enmesh them all." It's an adult, Iago, who says that in Othello. And it's grownups that Machiavelli was writing about when he wrote The Prince , his book about manipulating others and seizing power. Notice he titled the book The Prince , not The Little Prince. The Little Prince is actually by somebody else, if you don't know that.
“我要将这瘟疫灌入他的耳中，我将设下罗网，将他们一网打尽。” 这话出自《奥赛罗》中的伊阿古，一位成年人。马基雅维利在撰写《君主论》时，书中关于操纵他人和夺取权力的内容，讨论的对象也是成年人。注意他将书名定为《君主论》（The Prince），而不是《小王子》（The Little Prince）。如果你不知道的话，得提一下，《小王子》是另一位作者写的。
But in our American lives, the real era of intrigue and manipulation for most of us is not adulthood. It's adolescence, when our social circle is at its most constricting. Today on our program, a story of betrayal and of someone who holds David Koresh-like powers over others, and who is only in the seventh grade. From WBEZ in Chicago, it's Your Radio Playhouse . I'm Ira Glass.
但在我们的美国生活中，对大多数人来说，真正的阴谋与操纵时期并非成年，而是青春期，那时我们的社交圈最为狭窄。今天我们的节目将讲述一个背叛的故事，主角是一个在七年级就对他人生杀予夺，拥有大卫·考雷什般权力的人。这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《你的广播剧场》（Your Radio Playhouse），我是艾拉·格拉斯。
But before we get into the body of our story, we will try, as adults, to manipulate you a little bit at Pledge Central. Let's check in with Pledge Central. Shirley Jahad.
但在进入故事正题之前，我们要以成年人的身份，在认捐中心（Pledge Central）稍微“操纵”一下各位。让我们连线认捐中心，雪莉·贾哈德。
Hi, Ira Glass.
你好，艾拉·格拉斯。
Hi.
你好。
We're trying to manipulate the Radio Playhouse listeners, are we?
我们打算操纵“广播剧场”的听众吗？
I guess "manipulate" has the tune of a negative connotation.
我想“操纵”这个词听起来带有负面意味。
Oh, encourage, cajole, lure, maybe?
哦，那换成鼓励、劝诱、引诱怎么样？
Yeah, and we have all these--
对，我们有这些……
Entice, how about?
勾引呢？怎么样？
Entice. Entice is a very--
勾引。勾引是一个非常……
Seduce?
诱惑？
Keep going, baby. You're on a roll. You're on such a roll here. Sure.
继续，宝贝。你状态不错，说得真顺口。没错。
Well, let's seduce them with this phone number.
好吧，让我们用这个电话号码来诱惑他们。
What is the phone number?
电话号码是多少？
We've got to seduce them with this phone number. 312-832-3160. Stop the music dramatically as I say the number.
我们得用这个号码诱惑他们。312-832-3160。在我说出号码时，戏剧性地停止音乐。
Do it again.
再来一次。
312-832-3160. Maybe a little radio hypnotism. 312-832-3160. Call that number to pledge your support.
312-832-3160。也许来点电台催眠术。312-832-3160。拨打这个号码认捐以表达支持。
And I just want to say that we are so anxious to get you to call. We have very special premiums that we're offering during the coming hour that are available at no other time during the drive. We have three and a half or four, depending on how you count them. The very first one-- I'm going to play a little clip of these. These are all audio things. Well, how to begin with this?
我只想说，我们非常迫切地希望你们拨打电话。在接下来的一个小时里，我们将提供非常特别的赠品，这些赠品在筹款期间的其他任何时间都无法获得。根据统计方式的不同，我们有三点五个或四个。第一个——我要播放一小段音频片段。这些都是音频资料。嗯，该从哪里开始呢？
Explain it, Ira.
解释一下吧，艾拉。
Well, one of them is we have a cassette of recent work by David Sedaris, much of it heard here on Your Radio Playhouse , some of it heard on Morning Edition . This is all new work, including two radio dramas by the Pinetree Gang, which appear here on Your Radio Playhouse . That's one thing.
好吧，其中之一是戴维·塞达里斯近期作品的磁带，大部分曾在《你的广播剧场》中播出，有些则是在《早间版》中。这些都是新作，包括两部松树帮（Pinetree Gang）的广播剧，它们也出现在《你的广播剧场》中。这是其一。
Another thing is we have this very odd CD called Shut Up, Little Man , which listeners to the show heard. It's a sort of audio verite of these two men recorded through the walls of their apartment as they argued with each other.
另一个是这张非常奇怪的 CD，叫《闭嘴，小矮子》（Shut Up, Little Man），听众们应该听过。这是一种音频写实作品，记录了两个男人在公寓墙后争吵的内容。
And finally, we have this thing. Two weeks ago, we had a show where Julia Sweeney told the story of getting cancer. And she told the story of herself getting cancer and of her brother getting cancer. And she told them as stand-up comedy. And she was telling this in a place called Un-Cabaret. It's a club in Los Angeles where essentially, comics come each week, and they tell what are basically comic diary versions of their week.
最后，我们还有这个。两周前，我们有一期节目，茱莉亚·斯威尼讲述了她患癌症的故事。她讲述了自己患癌以及她哥哥患癌的经历。她以单口喜剧的形式讲述这些故事。她是在一个叫“非歌舞表演”（Un-Cabaret）的地方表演的。那是一家位于洛杉矶的俱乐部，喜剧演员们每周都会来这里，分享他们本周生活的喜剧日记版本。
And Un-Cabaret has a CD that's really pretty wonderful with some well-known people and some not-so-well-known people. And here's a sample. They have about 10 minutes of Julia Sweeney's cancer stories. Here's a sample of that.
“非歌舞表演”有一张非常精彩的 CD，里面既有知名人士，也有不太出名的人。这里是一小段摘录。他们有大约 10 分钟茱莉亚·斯威尼关于癌症的故事。请听这段摘录。
OK, so we're in the doctor's office, and Mike, who's doing really great and is responding really well to the treatment. But he's had so many spinal taps that they can't get into his spinal column anymore. So the doctor comes in. My dad's reading about the plague in India, because that's a good diversion. And my mom is looking at the doctors and saying, "Now, he looks single."
好了，我们在医生办公室，迈克恢复得非常好，对治疗反应也很理想。但他做了太多次脊椎穿刺，医生已经没法再从他的脊椎柱进针了。医生进来了。我爸正在看关于印度瘟疫的书，因为这是一种很好的消遣。而我妈看着那些医生，说道：“看，那个医生好像单身。”
And his doctor comes in. He says, "Michael, we can't get into your spinal column anymore, so we're thinking about putting a shunt in your head. And my brother goes, "What?" He goes, "A shunt?" And I go, "A shunt, like, an artificial opening to the brain." And Mike goes, "Well, where would this shunt be?" And the doctor goes, "Well, the best place we've found is to put it in the forehead."
他的医生进来说：“迈克尔，我们无法再进入你的脊椎柱了，所以我们在考虑给你的脑部安装一个分流器。” 我哥问：“什么？” 他说：“分流器？” 我说：“分流器，就像通往大脑的人造开口。” 迈克问：“那这分流器会装在哪？” 医生说：“嗯，我们发现最好的位置是安装在前额。”
And Mike goes, "If you think I am going to get a faucet put into my forehead. I'm already 90 pounds, and I have no hair. I'm not going to walk around for a year with a faucet sticking out of my forehead." And my mom goes, "No, I think it's more like a spigot."
迈克说：“如果你觉得我会在额头上装个水龙头，那就大错特错了。我已经瘦到 90 磅了，头发也没了。我才不要带着个水龙头在额头上走上一年。” 我妈说：“不，我觉得那更像是一个水龙头开关（spigot）。”
All right, so that's Julia Sweeney. If you want that and more-- and more diary entries from Janeane Garofalo and people who seem less well known. But there's Julia Sweeney, Janeane Garofalo, Beth Lapides, Bob Goldthwait, Taylor Negron, Dana Gould, other people. Ask for that when you call. 832-3160. Shirley, you're still there, right?
好了，那是茱莉亚·斯威尼。如果你想要这个以及更多内容——还有更多珍妮·加罗法洛和其他不太出名的人的日记条目。但里面有茱莉亚·斯威尼、珍妮·加罗法洛、贝丝·拉皮德斯、鲍勃·戈德斯韦特、泰勒·内格隆、达纳·古尔德等人的表演。打电话时请说明想要这个。832-3160。雪莉，你还在吗？
832-3160, yeah.
832-3160，在的。
And, Shirley, what is the magic word? We haven't even gotten to the extra-special premium. What is the magic word?
雪莉，那句魔咒是什么？我们还没说到那个超级特别的赠品呢。魔咒是什么？
Oh, the extra-special $4.95-- for $4.95, you can super size it.
哦，那个超级特别的 4.95 美元——只要 4.95 美元，你就可以进行“超值升级”（super size it）。
You can super size it. That's right. If you make the $60 pledge and just say super size it, for another $4.95, you get--
你可以进行“超值升级”。没错。如果你认捐 60 美元，只要说“超值升级”，再加 4.95 美元，你就能得到——
More "La Bamba" than you can handle.
更多你承受不了的《拉班巴》（La Bamba）。
Here we go. I think I've got it. This one starts kind of slow. This is a punk "La Bamba." They have a little collection of all sorts of "La Bambas." It's one of the most covered songs in music. We have the Mormon Tabernacle Choir. We have punk versions. We have Neil Diamond. This is kind of a surf version. Again, we want you to pledge. We want to please you.
开始吧。我想我找到了。这首节奏有点慢。这是一首朋克版的《拉班巴》。他们收藏了各种各样的《拉班巴》。这是音乐史上翻唱次数最多的歌曲之一。我们有摩门会幕合唱团版本，我们有朋克版本，我们有尼尔·戴蒙德版本。这是一首冲浪摇滚风格的。再说一遍，我们希望你认捐。我们希望让你满意。
We want you to pledge and then to super size it. 312-832-3160. Come on, go for extra fries and an extra large drink. 312-832-3160. Sorry, Ira.
我们希望你认捐，然后进行“超值升级”。312-832-3160。来吧，加份特大薯条和超大杯饮料。312-832-3160。抱歉，艾拉。
No, that's OK. So the idea is 60 bucks for one of the premia and $64.95 for one of the premia plus--
不，没关系。所以主意是认捐 60 美元获得其中一件赠品，或者 64.95 美元获得一件赠品外加——
90 minutes of "La Bamba." Take it on vacation with you, right? To the Caribbean.
90 分钟的《拉班巴》。带上它去度假吧，好吗？去加勒比海。
It makes a fine, fine summertime present for anyone.
这对于任何人来说都是一份非常棒的夏季礼物。
That's right. 312-832-3160. Call now to pledge your support for Your Radio Playhouse.
没错。312-832-3160。现在就拨打电话，认捐支持《你的广播剧场》。
OK, Shirley. I'll check back with you in a bit.
好了，雪莉。一会儿再找你。
Thanks, Ira.
谢谢，艾拉。
So let's get to today's story on this, our radio show. This is a story of enemies. But some of the bitterest enemies are people who used to be close friends. And our story begins with the friendship of these two boys named Bob and Dave. And today's program will be in four acts. Act One, Dave's Love.
现在让我们进入今天电台节目的故事。这是一个关于敌人的故事。但一些最苦涩的敌人往往是曾经最亲密的朋友。我们的故事始于两个名叫鲍勃和戴夫的男孩之间的友谊。今天的节目将分为四幕。第一幕：戴夫的爱。
Act Two, Dave's Hate.
第二幕：戴夫的恨。
Act Three, Dave Today.
第三幕：今天的戴夫。
Act Four, Another Dave. That another Dave is David Sedaris, actually. We have a story by David Sedaris coming up.
第四幕：另一个戴夫。那个“另一个戴夫”其实就是戴维·塞达里斯。我们稍后会播出戴维·塞达里斯的故事。
So, Act One. Our story takes place in a small town somewhere on the East Coast.
好了，第一幕。我们的故事发生在美国东海岸的一个小镇上。
Dave and I became friends in fourth grade, and we were friends through sixth grade. And I have to describe him physically because that's a huge part of his personality. He was-- and he still is-- an extremely wiry person. Very thin. He looks emaciated. And he also, his skin is like a jaundiced yellow color. He was always very acned. Just very pale, pasty, and he just looked sick.
戴夫和我在四年级成为朋友，一直到六年级。我必须描述一下他的外表，因为那是他个性中很大的一部分。他非常瘦骨嶙峋，现在也是。他看起来很消瘦。而且他的皮肤呈现出一种黄疸般的黄色。他总是长满痤疮。非常苍白，病恹恹的，看起来像个病人。
I don't really know how we became friends. We were in class together in grade school. But as things progressed into fifth grade, it became pretty clear that our friendship was the most intense friendship in the class. We would talk on the phone at least once a day and for hours. We would just talk for hours and just make each other laugh so hard. And that was why we always got separated in class was just because we weren't troublemakers, we just made each other laugh a lot. We had very similar senses of humor.
我其实不知道我们是怎么成为朋友的。我们在小学同班。但随着五年级的到来，很明显我们的友谊是班上最深厚的。我们至少每天通一次电话，一聊就是几个小时。我们只是聊天，把对方逗得大笑不已。我们总是被老师分开，并不是因为我们捣乱，只是因为我们太能逗对方笑了。我们的幽默感非常相似。
The scatological jokes were the primary jokes. And I was just thinking about this today. I remembered this one thing that we used to do, which we did obsessively. It's embarrassing to say it, but we were obsessed with the words "poop" and "pee." And we made this little thing where I would say "poop" and he would say "pee," and then he would say "wee," and then I would say "gilly gee." And so it'd go kind of like, poop, pee, wee, gilly gee. And we said this over and over and over again. And we used to just take books and just insert the words "poop" and "pee" everywhere.
排泄物的笑话是我们的主打。我今天还在想这事。我记得我们过去痴迷做的一件事，虽然现在说出来很尴尬，但我们当时沉迷于“便便”（poop）和“嘘嘘”（pee）这两个词。我们编了个小段子，我说“便便”，他说“嘘嘘”，然后他说“微（wee）”，接着我说“吉利基（gilly gee）”。就这样一直重复：便便、嘘嘘、微、吉利基。我们一遍又一遍地念叨。我们还喜欢把书里的内容都换成“便便”和“嘘嘘”。
And "wee" was like the one word that was just, for some reason, that was like our rallying call. That was like our motto. We just said it all the time. Just "wee." Wee! We used to do that all the time. Wee!
“微”是那个不知为何成了我们口头禅的词。那是我们的座右铭。我们总是说。就说“微”。微！我们经常那样做。微！
Some of the other stuff that we had in common-- our favorite group was The Village People. And we used to listen to The Village People all the time and just totally obsess about them, having no idea what they were singing about at all. And the Dukes of Hazzard was another one, and Star Wars . Those were very big things. And sports.
我们还有其他共同点——我们最喜欢的团体是“乡村音乐人”（Village People）。我们总是听他们的歌，完全痴迷于他们，尽管根本不知道他们在唱什么。还有《哈扎德公爵》（Dukes of Hazzard）和《星球大战》。那些都是大事。还有运动。
I basically discovered sexuality through him. And we used to play spin the bottle in his room. And we would take off an article of clothing when it would land on us. And it was the first time we'd ever been naked in front of another person except for our parents. And it was petrifying, but it was also just this whole discovery period of seeing another man naked there.
我基本上是通过他发现了性。我们过去在他的房间里玩转瓶子游戏。转到谁，谁就脱下一件衣服。这是我们除父母外第一次在别人面前赤身裸体。这太令人惊恐了，但也确实是一个探索另一个男性裸体的时期。
And it became this whole game that we played often. And we would revel in the fact of standing there in front of each other totally naked, assuming these characters like, "Hi, Mr. Jones. How are you? Nice to meet you." Businessmen and everything, just standing there completely buck naked and so terrified that we were ever going to get caught, because his parents were always home. They were always in the house and everything, and we were just so afraid that someone was going to knock on the door.
这成了一种我们常玩的游戏。我们喜欢那种在彼此面前全身赤裸的感觉，还假装扮演角色，比如：“你好，琼斯先生。见到你很高兴。” 扮演商人之类的，全身光溜溜地站着，非常害怕被发现，因为他父母总在家。他们总在屋里，我们太怕有人突然敲门了。
The one time that was the biggest scare was he-- Dave basically could get anybody to do anything that he wanted them to do. And he had a camera and was-- these times when I'd go up to his house were fully documented events. He's very anal retentive. And he loved documenting everything was going on.
最惊险的一次是——戴夫基本上能让任何人做他想做的事。他有台相机——我去他家的那几次都被完整地记录了下来。他有严重的强迫症，喜欢记录发生的一切。
So he would have a camera and take a lot of pictures. And he wanted me to pull down my pants and take a picture of me with my pants down. And I was refusing to do it. I would not let it be caught on film. And he was just insisting, and he went through this entire-- I mean, he was trying to coax me for so long, telling me all these different things that he was going to do for me and saying, "Oh, nobody's going to see it." And he came up with this whole scheme of how nobody would see the film and everything and just these elaborate, elaborate plans on how nobody would see these pictures. And I just kept refusing and refusing and refusing.
所以他拿着相机拍了很多照片。他想让我脱下裤子，拍张露屁股的照片。我拒绝了。我不想让它被拍下来。他一直坚持，缠了我好久，许诺给我做这做那，说：“哦，没人会看到的。” 他想出了各种复杂的方案，保证没人会看到胶卷。我一直拒绝，一直拒绝。
And finally, at the end of it, he was like, "All right, just take down you pants anyway. I won't take a picture. I swear to you. I won't take a picture, I promise." And I still didn't believe him. And he was like, "Look, I promise. I promise. I promise," This went on for like an hour, of him trying to coax me to take my pants down. And he promised me, bottom of his heart, that he was not going to take a picture.
最后，他妥协了：“好吧，把裤子脱下来就行。我不拍。我发誓，我保证不拍。” 我还是不信。他说：“看，我保证。我保证。我保证。” 这持续了一个小时，他试图诱导我脱裤子。他发自内心地保证他不会拍照。
And so I was like, fine. So I like unbuckled my belt, and I unbuckled my pants. And I pulled down my zipper, and I whipped open my pants. And I had my underwear on. And then I put myself all back together again. And when I had my pants open, he took a picture. And I was like, "Ah!"
于是我说，好吧。我解开皮带，解开裤扣，拉开拉链，猛地把裤子脱了下来。我穿着内裤。然后我又穿好了。就在我脱裤子的时候，他拍了一张照片。我惊叫道：“啊！”
And I was terrified because when you're that age, when you're 11 and 12 years old, you can't go in and get your pictures developed yourself and pay for them and get them. And I thought, somebody is going to get these pictures developed, and somebody is going to see them.
我吓坏了，因为在你那个年纪，11、12岁的时候，你没法自己去洗照片、付钱拿照片。我心想，有人会洗这些照片，有人会看到它们。
So weeks later, I was going up to his house again. And in the car going up to his house-- his mother was driving-- he was like, "I got the pictures back." And I said, "Oh, my god." And he was like, "You're not going to believe what's on there." And I said, "But what can be? You didn't see anything." And he's like, "I know, but you have to see this because it's there." And I was like, "But it can't be because I didn't take my pants down." And he was like, "I know, but it's there. It's there. You have to see it."
几周后，我又去他家。在车上——他妈妈在开车——他说：“照片洗出来了。” 我说：“天哪。” 他说：“你绝对想不到上面有什么。” 我说：“能有什么？你又没拍到什么。” 他说：“我知道，但你必须看看，因为上面有东西。” 我说：“不可能，我没脱内裤。” 他说：“我知道，但确实有。就在那。你得看看。”
He pulls out the pictures, and I looked at it. And my penis was hanging out there. And I was like, "But I didn't do it." And he was like, "You must've." And I said, "But I know I didn't. I know I just opened my pants." And he said, "You must've done it. Maybe it just fell out or something." And I said, "But it can't be." And we racked our brains just trying to figure out what had happened, because I knew that I hadn't pulled my underwear down.
他拿出照片，我一看。我的阴茎露在外面。我说：“但我没那样做啊。” 他说：“你一定做了。” 我说：“我确定我没做。我只开了裤子。” 他说：“你肯定做了。也许它自己掉出来了。” 我说：“不可能。” 我们绞尽脑汁想发生了什么，因为我知道我没脱内裤。
So that night, we were at a high school football game. And we were looking at the pictures again, just examining them. We were way up in the bleachers in a corner. And we took them out, and we were looking at them. And we were trying to explain what had happened. And finally, we figured out that it was the inside of my belt that looked like my penis.
那天晚上，我们在看高中橄榄球比赛。我们又在检查照片。我们坐在看台角落的顶端。我们拿出来看，试图解释发生了什么。最后我们发现，原来是我皮带的内侧看起来像我的阴茎。
And we're like, "Oh!" And so I was completely relieved, but I made him-- I watched him just tear up the picture into a thousand pieces and went through this whole elaborate method to bury the pieces in the bottom of a trash can at this football stadium. And I was still petrified that somebody was going to find them and piece them together.
我们惊呼：“噢！” 我彻底松了口气，但我还是盯着他把那张照片撕得粉碎，还通过一种极其复杂的手段把碎片埋进橄榄球场的垃圾桶底部。我还是很害怕有人会发现并把它们拼凑起来。
The point that it started to change was, as we were going into sixth grade, we were constantly being separated in class. And that's around the time when people start to realize that there's a difference between someone who's straight and someone who's gay. And there was just grumblings happening. People were accusing us of being homosexual.
情况开始转变是在六年级，我们在课堂上经常被分开。那正是人们开始意识到异性恋和同性恋区别的时候。开始有流言蜚语了。有人指责我们是同性恋。
And we weren't in any way, but we also knew of all the things that we had done with each other in each other's presence. And I think when people started to think that we were gay, that just rose to the surface, and we realized that there was a cool thing and a not cool thing. And we were definitely not cool in the friendship that we were in.
我们根本不是，但我们也知道我们曾一起做过的一切。我想当人们开始觉得我们是同性恋时，那些事就浮出水面了，我们意识到什么事是“酷”的，什么事是“不酷”的。在我们的友谊中，我们显然很不酷。
And that's also around that time when-- in my town, at least, and I think in a lot of small towns-- is where sports just become the most important thing in your life. And I was not a good athlete then at all. Dave was a good athlete. And Dave organized a big football party one weekend where we were going to go out there and play football and have a sleepover and then the next day, play more football.
大约也是在那时——至少在我所在的镇上，我想在很多小镇也是这样——体育运动成了你生活中最重要的事。我当时根本不是个好运动员。戴夫是个好运动员。那个周末，戴夫组织了一个盛大的橄榄球派对，我们去那儿踢球、过夜，第二天继续踢。
Dave just organized this thing unbelievably. He had jerseys printed up with numbers and names on them. He had teams with rosters. He had practice for his team with plays. There was a playbook. This is for a little football game, like three-on-three football or four-on-four football. Touch football.
戴夫组织得好得不可思议。他印制了带有号码和名字的球衣。他分了队，还有花名册。他带着他的球队训练，还有战术。有一本战术手册。这只是一场小小的橄榄球赛，比如三对三或四对四的腰旗橄榄球。
And every single minute was decided upon beforehand by him as to what we would do, where we would be, what we would eat, the food we would eat, when we would play football. It was all timed out. He was so organized and anal retentive about it. I don't remember very well, but I can't imagine that I played tremendously well.
每一分钟都在事前由他定好了，我们做什么、在哪儿、吃什么、什么时候踢球。一切都按时间表进行。他组织得井井有条，有严重的强迫症。我记不清了，但我敢肯定我踢得非常糟糕。
I was thinking about this today. I was trying to think of the moment when everything changed. And I'm almost positive it was that event. It was the football party. And immediately after that, he just totally stopped talking to me.
我今天一直在想这件事。我试图找出一切改变的那一刻。我几乎可以肯定就是那个活动，橄榄球派对。在那之后，他就完全不跟我说话了。
How Dave turned the class against Bob, as our show continues.
戴夫是如何煽动全班同学对抗鲍勃的，节目继续。
Well, it is Your Radio Playhouse. And we do want you to call 832-3160. Area code 312. Hey, Shirley Jahad, are you there?
这里是《你的广播剧场》。请拨打 832-3160。区号 312。嘿，雪莉·贾哈德，你在吗？
Hey, Ira Glass.
嘿，艾拉·格拉斯。
Hey, honey.
嘿，亲爱的。
This is an intriguing little tale.
这是一个引人入胜的小故事。
Well, as we try to present here on this, our little Radio Playhouse radio show. Are people calling?
好吧，正如我们试图在这档小电台节目中所呈现的那样。有人打电话吗？
People are calling. 312-832-3160. I don't have the exact count yet, but the phones are ringing. And people are super-sizing their pledges.
有人在打。312-832-3160。我还没有具体统计，但电话一直在响。人们正在把认捐额度“超值升级”。
Wait, you said the magic word, which means I have to get rid of this music and bring on-- here it is. Do you recognize this, Shirley?
等等，你说了那个魔咒，这意味着我得关掉音乐，换成——就是这个。你认得这个吗，雪莉？
Could it be? It's a familiar yet foreign.
难道是？听起来熟悉又陌生。
This is the Mormon Tabernacle Choir version of "La Bamba," which appears to you when you say the word "super size."
这是摩门会幕合唱团版本的《拉班巴》，当你说了“超值升级”时就会出现。
Super size your pledge for $4.95, and you get 90 minutes of "La Bamba."
只要额外认捐 4.95 美元进行“超值升级”，你就能得到 90 分钟的《拉班巴》。
Blessing or a curse. And remember our three special premia. One is the Un-Cabaret CD, which is basically comics telling stories about their own lives. The second thing is the Shut Up, Little Man CD. And the third thing is David Sedaris, including lots of material heard on this program, but also, for example, the Christmas--
是福还是祸。记住我们的三项特别赠品。一个是“非歌舞表演”的 CD，主要是喜剧演员讲述自己的生活故事；第二个是《闭嘴，小矮子》CD；第三个是戴维·塞达里斯的磁带，包括本节目中播出的许多素材，但也包括，例如，那个圣诞——
SantaLand Diaries.
《圣地日记》（SantaLand Diaries）。
No, I feel like we've given that away too many times. I'm sorry. But this year, David did a story for Morning Edition that we had to cut about three minutes out to fit it into a Morning Edition segment. People who buy the cassette will get the uncut version. And it's the story about how he was having a bad Christmas one year until his sister brought home a prostitute who she knew from work.
不，我觉得我们已经播太多次了，很抱歉。但今年，戴维为《早间版》写了一个故事，我们不得不剪掉三分钟才塞进《早间版》的片段里。购买磁带的听众将得到未删减版本。这是一个关于他某年圣诞节过得很糟的故事，直到他姐姐带回一个她在工作中认识的妓女。
"What were the prison guards really like?" Amy asked. "Which do you like better, spending the night with strange guys or working in a cafeteria?" Tiffany tried on Donna's shoes while Gretchen modeled her jacket.
“那些监狱看守真的怎么样？”艾米问。“你更喜欢和陌生男人过夜，还是在食堂工作？” 蒂芙尼试穿了唐娜的鞋子，而格雷琴在试她的外套。
"Donna the Christmas Whore."
“圣诞妓女唐娜”。
Oh, my. Ho, ho, ho.
哦，天哪。吼，吼，吼。
Yeah, ho, ho, ho. And what's the number again?
是的，吼，吼，吼。号码是多少来着？
312-832-3160.
312-832-3160。
A heart-warming story for the whole family.
一个适合全家老小的暖心故事。
Like this one we're in the middle of. 312-832-3160. A slew of premiums. All kinds of great comedy and performance and storytelling and wonderful music. 90-minute cassette of "La Bamba" in many varieties. 312-832-3160. If you say "super size it," those volunteers will know what you mean.
就像我们正在讲述的这个一样。312-832-3160。大量的赠品。各种伟大的喜剧、表演、故事和美妙的音乐。90 分钟各种版本的《拉班巴》磁带。312-832-3160。如果你说“超值升级”，志愿者们会明白你的意思。
In fact, you can get any premium that the station is selling. Anything. Anything you've heard all day and that you're going to hear all week, and just say "super size it." Only during this show. At $4.95, you get that "La Bamba" tape.
事实上，你可以获得电台出售的任何赠品。任何东西。只要你今天听到的、这周会听到的，说一声“超值升级”就行。仅限本节目期间。只需 4.95 美元，你就能得到那盘《拉班巴》磁带。
Your Radio Playhouse . 312-832-3160.
《你的广播剧场》。312-832-3160。
Check back with you later, Shirley.
一会儿再找你，雪莉。
Thanks, Ira.
谢谢，艾拉。
Act Two, Dave's Hatred. Dave and Bob were best friends. And now Dave started using all the tactics that adults use in political situations, in power situations, all the tactics one uses to turn people against one another. Whispering in ears, things like that. Bob, who's now a theater director in New York City, by the way, Bob tells the story.
第二幕：戴夫的恨。戴夫和鲍勃曾是最好的朋友。现在戴夫开始使用成人在政治斗争、权力斗争中使用的所有策略——那些煽动人们相互敌对的策略。耳边细语之类的。顺便说一句，鲍勃现在是纽约市的戏剧导演。鲍勃讲述了这个故事。
I remember going into class in seventh grade on the first day of school and him not talking to me and everybody just wondering. The whole school was wondering why there was this big fight going on between Dave and Bob. And I remember not having an answer for anybody. I used to tell them to ask Dave. I had no idea. And I used to tell people that he just stopped talking to me. And I remember that he became completely bent on turning everyone against me. The whole school. And he did it very well because he's so organized and because he's so manipulative.
我记得七年级开学第一天去学校，他不跟我说话，每个人都在纳闷。整个学校都在奇怪戴夫和鲍勃之间出了什么大问题。我不记得当时给过任何人答复。我只会让他们去问戴夫。我根本不知道。我告诉人们他只是不理我了。我记得他完全一心想要把所有人变成我的敌人。全校学生。他做得非常出色，因为他太有组织能力，太善于操纵了。
And I saw him. And I saw him telling people to say things to me. And he was one who formed the I Hate-- they used to call me [? Cooze ?] then. And he was the one who formed the I Hate [? Cooze ?] Club. He never did anything to me himself. He would never come up to me and make fun of me. He would never come up to me and hit me. He would never assault me personally. But he would just get everyone else to do it for him.
我看着他。我看他指使别人来针对我。他组建了——他们那时叫我 [? Cooze ?] ——他组建了“我恨 [? Cooze ?] 俱乐部”。他自己从不直接针对我。他从不跑过来嘲弄我。他从不跑过来打我。他从不亲自动手。但他会让所有其他人都替他做。
So he would send people to say things to me. I remember one time in the lunchroom Sam saying, have you ever been caught masturbating? And of course, either answer is-- you damn yourself if you answer yes or if you answer no. And I remember hearing Dave tell him to ask me that.
他会指使别人跑来找我茬。我记得有一次在食堂，山姆问我：你有没有被抓到过在自慰？当然，回答是或否，无论你怎么答都是个坑。我记得当时亲耳听到戴夫让山姆来问我这个。
I used to just get made fun of horrendously by everyone. People would make fun of the way that I chewed at lunch. People would make fun of the way that I laughed. People would make fun of the way that I coughed, that I sneezed. People would make fun of the way that I walked. There was just this teasing. But that makes it even sound less violent than it was. It was just a mocking. It was a very pointed mocking on everyone's part.
我一直被大家疯狂地嘲弄。人们嘲笑我午餐时的咀嚼方式。嘲笑我的笑声。嘲笑我咳嗽、打喷嚏的方式。嘲笑我的走路姿势。这种戏弄……即使这样说也显得这不够暴力。那纯粹是讥讽。每个人都针对我进行极其刻薄的讥讽。
I remember sitting alone at the lunch table with no one to talk to and just wanting so badly for no one to turn their attention to me because I knew that the attention would be negative. I remember not understanding what was going on. I had been in such a sweet position with this person. We had such a good friendship. And then, all of a sudden, everyone had just turned against me.
我记得独自坐在午餐桌旁，无人说话，只祈祷没有人注意到我，因为我知道一旦被注意到，得到的肯定是负面评价。我不明白发生了什么。我曾和这个人关系那么好。我们有那么深厚的友谊。然后，突然之间，所有人都针对我了。
And he wasn't like a pied piper. He was so subtle, and he was so quiet. I don't think he ever had a friendship with people like he had with me. But he was just able to organize people into these different factions. He would just say, "Go over to [? Cooze ?] and just shove him into a locker." And they'd go do it.
他不像吹笛人。他太微妙，太安静了。我不认为他后来和别人建立过像和我那样的友谊。但他就是有能力把人组织成不同的派系。他只会说：“去 [? Cooze ?] 那边，把他塞进储物柜里。” 然后他们就会去照做。
That was the worst period, I think, of my entire life was that period. I used to go home from school and cry after school. I used to go to my dog and hug my dog and say, you are my only friend in the world.
那可能是我人生中最糟糕的一段时期。放学后我经常回家哭。我抱着我的狗对它说，你是世界上我唯一的朋友。
Then he started to kind of needle me. I remember one thing that he did was there was this guy, Mike, in my class. And Mike was what we called in my hometown a scummer, which meant that he was on welfare. He perhaps didn't have a pair of pants for every day of the week. He was very smart, which was a strike against him at that age. And he just didn't fit in. He was a real geek. So Dave organized this fight between Mike and I-- a fist fight to prove who was the bigger faggot. Whoever would lose was the bigger faggot.
然后他开始找茬。我记得他做过的一件事是，班上有个叫迈克的家伙。迈克在我们家乡被称为“社会底层”（scummer），意味着他领救济金。他可能连每天换洗的裤子都没有。他很聪明，但在那个年纪这反而是个缺点。他不合群。他是个真正的怪胎。所以戴夫组织了我和迈克之间的一场架——通过打拳来证明谁才是那个更大的“娘炮”。输的人就是更大的那个。
And he positioned us-- he spun it so there was no way I could not fight. If I didn't have this fight, then things would just get worse for me. Things would get worse. Mike was at the bottom of the barrel, and I was there with him. And Dave had to prove that I was below him. And so he organized this whole fight. And everyone in the class was like, "Are you going to fight Mike? Are you going to fight Mike?"
他设好局，让我根本没法不打。如果我不打，情况只会更糟。迈克本来就在社会底层，我当时也和他一起在那儿。戴夫必须证明我比他更低。于是他组织了那场架。班上每个人都在说：“你会打迈克吗？你会打迈克吗？”
And I finally conceded. I conceded to fight him. Dave organized the whole event. It was to happen at this playground. And we went, and he tried to get this whole audience to come and see it. Unfortunately, nobody came but him-- well, I guess, fortunately. Nobody came but him and one other person.
我终于让步了。我同意跟他打。戴夫组织了一切。地点在操场。我们去了，他试图让全班都来看。不幸的是，没人来——或者说幸运的是。除了他还有另一个人，没人来。
So Mike and I went there. And neither of us wanted to fight each other. Neither of us had any reason in the world to fight each other. So I just remember standing there facing him, just laughing, just like, what are we supposed to do? We're standing here. We've been forced into this just to save our own souls. And now we have to inflict pain on each other. And we stood there for the longest time. And Dave kept trying to push us into fighting. He was saying, "Come on. Just throw a punch. Just throw a punch. Just start."
我和迈克到了那里。我们谁都不想打谁。我们毫无理由要打架。我记得我站在那儿对着他笑，想的是：我们到底该干什么？我们在这儿，只是被迫为了保住自己的尊严。而现在我们却要彼此伤害。我们站了很久。戴夫不停地催促我们动手。他说：“来吧。挥拳啊。挥拳啊。开始啊。”
We waited for the longest time, and then finally, I was just like, this is ridiculous. So I went up, and I shoved him. And then we started to fight. We weren't really into fighting, but we had to do it then. And I pushed him at one point, and he fell backwards and he hurt his wrist. And I got on top of him. and I held his wrist. And I remember saying to him, "Do you give up?" And he wouldn't give up. And I was holding his wrist back.
我们站了很久，最后我觉得：这也太荒谬了。于是我走过去推了他一下。然后我们开始打架。我们其实并不想打，但当时不得不打。打着打着，我推了他一下，他向后摔倒，手腕受伤了。我压在他身上，抓着他的手腕。我记得我对他说：“你认输吗？” 他不肯认输。我抓着他的手腕。
And each time I kept asking if he was going to give up, and he kept saying no. And each time he'd say no, I'd bend his wrist back a little bit more. And he was crying in pain. And I kept saying, I'm going to bend it back. I'm going to bend it back. I'm going to bend it back, thinking, I don't want to break this person's wrist. I have no reason to break this person's wrist.
每次我问他认不认输，他都说不。每当他说不，我就把他的手腕再往后扳一点。他痛得大哭。我嘴里说着，我要扳下去了，我要扳下去了，我想的是：我不想弄断这人的手腕。我没有理由弄断他的手腕。
And I was faced at that moment with either giving up and getting kicked even more or going ahead with really hurting this person and hoping that it would save me in some way. And I broke his wrist. He came in the next day into school with a cast on. I don't know how his family paid for his cast. And everybody saw that and said, "You idiot, [? Cooze! ?] What did you do? You idiot!" And it made it even worse.
那一刻我面临抉择：要么认输被更严重地霸凌，要么继续伤人，希望能以此保住自己。我弄断了他的手腕。第二天他打着石膏来学校了。我不知道他家怎么付得起医药费。大家都看到了，指着我说：“你这白痴，[? Cooze !] 你干了什么？你这个白痴！” 情况变得更糟了。
I just didn't understand. I didn't know what was going on. That's the most frustrating for me, even still today. I always thought it was me. I always thought it was something I was doing. I thought it was the way that I wore my clothes. I thought it was the shoes that I wore. I thought it was the way that I laughed. I remember.
我就是不明白。我不知道发生了什么。即使到了今天，这也是最让我感到挫败的地方。我一直以为是我的错。我以为是我做了什么。我以为是我穿衣服的方式。我以为是我穿的鞋子。我以为是我笑的方式。我记得。
And I remember I tried to change these things. I tried not to laugh so loud. I tried to cough differently. They made fun of the most minuscule things that are just human, like chewing. If they would've noticed the way that I breathed, they would have made fun of that. I remember I tried lifting weights. And it was impossible, because there was nothing I could do to make them change their minds. If I lifted weights, it was the way that I lifted weights. They would come up with something.
我也记得我曾尝试改变这些。我试过不要大声笑。我试过改变咳嗽的方式。他们嘲笑最细微的东西，比如咀嚼。如果他们注意到我呼吸的方式，他们肯定也会拿那个开玩笑。我记得我曾尝试举重。但那是徒劳的，因为无论我怎么做，都无法改变他们的看法。即使我去举重，他们也会嘲笑我举重的方式。他们总能找到理由。
It was a no-win situation. And I guess I knew how smart he was, and I knew how well he knew me. And I guess, all of a sudden, I had thought that he had seen all these things in me that were just wrong, just so not cool.
这是一场必输的战斗。我猜我知道他有多聪明，我知道他有多了解我。我猜，突然间，我以为是他看透了我身上的一切缺点，那些真的不“酷”的地方。
I remember very clearly there was a moment that the clouds just cleared and everything became possible. I went to the Pennsylvania Governor's School for the Arts in my junior year. The summer between my junior and senior year, that was when I met people who were actors, like I was, who were my age and who respected me.
我清晰地记得，有一刻云开雾散，一切都变得可能了。我在高三那年去了宾夕法尼亚州州长艺术学校。那是高三和大四之间的暑假，在那里我遇到了和我同龄的、尊重我的演员朋友。
And I remember very clearly, it was after lunch, and people who were in my theater class, we were going down to the cafeteria. And I had forgotten my bag in the cafeteria. And I said, "Oh, just wait for me one second. I just want to get my bag." And I went down to the cafeteria, and I got my bag. And I came back up, and they were still there waiting for me. And I remember so distinctly remembering, "Oh, my god. These people, they waited for me."
我记忆犹新，那是午饭后，我戏剧课的同学正一起去食堂。我把包落在食堂了。我说：“噢，等我一下，我去拿包。” 我跑下楼拿了包，回来时他们还在那等我。我记得非常清楚，当时心想：“天哪。这些人，他们等我。”
That meant so much to me, because I felt like I'm not this idiot. I'm not this geek. I'm not a person who everyone should hate. I'm actually a pretty good human being, and people like me.
那对我来说意义重大，因为我感觉自己不是那个白痴。我不是个怪胎。我不是一个每个人都该憎恨的人。我实际上是一个挺好的人，人们喜欢我。
Sometimes, I feel like there's some justice in the fact that I'm surrounded now by many people who love me and respect me. And I don't know how many people he has in his life. But the tables have turned in that way.
有时候，我觉得现在的我被许多爱我、尊重我的人包围，这本身就是一种正义。我不知道他生活中有多少人。但在这个意义上，形势已经扭转了。
And when I go back home and I see people looking at me the way that they looked at me in high school, I think there is some justice in this, because those people are probably-- some of those people, I've heard, are in bad situations with their families. They've got wives they don't love. They've been through divorces. They don't have any friends. They're in the same bar they were in four or five years ago, drinking the same beer they drank. And their gut is a little bigger, and their nose is a little redder. And they just look tired. And I feel like my life is in pretty good shape, and I'm happy. And that's the sweetest revenge. And last Christmas, I ran into him at a mall. And he looked more jaundiced and more sickly than ever.
当我回到家乡，看到人们用高中时代那种眼光看我时，我觉得这就是正义，因为那些人……我听说有些人过得很糟。他们和不爱的妻子在一起。他们离过婚。没朋友。他们还在四五年前去的酒吧喝着同样的啤酒。肚子大了一点，鼻子红了一点。他们看起来只是很累。我觉得我的生活状态很不错，我很快乐。这就是最甜蜜的复仇。去年圣诞节，我在商场遇到了他。他看起来比以往任何时候都更加面色蜡黄、病态。
Bob says that it was because Dave made him an outcast in junior high school that he ended up spending a lot of time with the theater teacher. Because the other kids wouldn't talk to him. And this teacher put him in plays and took him to plays in New York City, showing him that there was a bigger world outside their hometown.
鲍勃说，正是因为戴夫在初中时把他变成了边缘人，他才花了很多时间与戏剧老师待在一起。因为其他孩子不跟他说话。这位老师让他参与演出，并带他去纽约市看剧，向他展示了家乡以外更广阔的世界。
If it weren't for Dave, I would not be doing what I'm doing right now. There's no way. I don't know what I would have been doing, but because of what he did to me, I found theater, and it's been a really good life so far.
如果不是戴夫，我现在绝对不会做我正在做的事。没可能。我不知道我会做什么，但因为他对我做的一切，我发现了戏剧，到目前为止，那是一段非常美好的人生。
Bob's a director in Manhattan. Dave gives his version of the story in Act Three of Your Radio Playhouse .
鲍勃是曼哈顿的一名导演。戴夫在《你的广播剧场》第三幕讲述了他的版本。
Hey, Shirley Jahad?
嘿，雪莉·贾哈德？
Yeah, Ira, man?
怎么了，艾拉？
I love when he says, "I'm going to shoot my buddy."
我喜欢他说“我要枪杀我的死党”那段。
They're just like, yeah!
他们只是说，耶！
The band just goes, like, yeah! They get so excited What a weird moment.
乐队只是说，耶！他们太兴奋了。多么奇怪的时刻。
Some parts of it are painful, Ira, to listen to. I bet some people have memories of difficulties in their youth.
有些部分挺痛的，艾拉，听着。我敢打赌有些人也有过青春期的阴影。
I think if you want to share, we're going to have to set aside more time--
我想如果你想分享，我们得留出更多时间——
Well, I'm not going to share. Don't worry. I won't.
噢，我不会分享的。别担心。我不会的。
Well, it's OK.
好吧，没关系。
You can call 312-832-3160, and you'll feel absolved of a lot of things. 312-832-3160.
你可以拨打 312-832-3160，你会觉得心中的重负减轻了很多。312-832-3160。
And what's that magic word? I keep forgetting it.
那句魔咒是什么？我老是忘。
And the magic word, once you call that number, and all the volunteers in that pledge room will know when you say "super size it."
魔咒就是，一旦你拨通那个号码，认捐室里的所有志愿者在听到你说“超值升级”时就会明白。
It's the disco version of "La Bamba," Shirley.
那是迪斯科版本的《拉班巴》，雪莉。
And all of the volunteers are dirty dancing right now, just so you know.
而且所有的志愿者现在都在跳疯狂舞蹈，只是让你知道。
That's right. If you say the thing about "La Bamba"-- if you say "super size it" for $4.95 extra, any premium this radio station has, including our three special premia tonight-- the Un-Cabaret CD, the David Sedaris tape, and the Shut Up, Little Man CD, they will throw in 90 minutes of various "La Bambas." on top of it.
没错。如果你说关于《拉班巴》的那件事——只要额外多认捐 4.95 美元进行“超值升级”，你就能获得电台提供的任何赠品，包括我们今晚的三款特别赠品——“非歌舞表演”CD、戴维·塞达里斯磁带和《闭嘴，小矮子》CD，他们会额外附赠 90 分钟各种版本的《拉班巴》。
A variety of "La Bambas." 312-832-3160, the number to call to support Your Radio Playhouse . We are looking for new members here on WBEZ in Chicago. And what better place to look than a new program, Your Radio Playhouse , a fantastic new addition to WBEZ's lineup. 312-832-3160. If you've been catching the program the last few shows and enjoying it, then give us a call now. 312-832-3160.
各种版本的《拉班巴》。312-832-3160，拨打这个号码支持《你的广播剧场》。我们正在芝加哥 WBEZ 招募新会员。还有什么地方比一个新节目更适合呢？《你的广播剧场》，WBEZ 阵容中一个精彩的新成员。312-832-3160。如果你过去几期听了节目并喜欢它，那就现在打电话给我们吧。312-832-3160。
And, Shirley, let me play another sample from this Un-Cabaret CD. Again, it's this unusual forum, which isn't exactly stand-up comedy. The comics come and tell stories about their own lives, every week in Los Angeles. If you were to fly to Los Angeles and go to this club, it would cost you hundreds and hundreds of dollars. But for just a $60 pledge, we're going to give you a CD, and for $64.95, a CD plus this fabulous music. And here's a sample of one of the bits. I'll just play it quick so people know what they're getting. This is a guy named Terry Sweeney. No relation to Julia Sweeney.
而且，雪莉，让我放一段“非歌舞表演”CD 里的样本。再说一遍，这是一个不寻常的论坛，不是那种标准的单口喜剧。喜剧演员们每周在洛杉矶聚在一起讲述自己的生活故事。如果你要飞到洛杉矶去那个俱乐部，那得花上好几百美元。但只需认捐 60 美元，我们就会送你一张 CD；如果认捐 64.95 美元，就能得到 CD 外加这美妙的音乐。这是其中的一小段。我快速播放一下，让大家知道他们得到的是什么。这是一个叫特里·斯威尼的人。和茱莉亚·斯威尼没关系。
I used to go to things like The Mine Shaft, which was in New York-- when I lived in New York-- which was much too hardcore for me. And people would be really dressed in these leather harnesses and leather caps and dog collars and totally done up. And I'd have tried to put on a black cardigan or something.
我过去常去那种叫“矿井”（The Mine Shaft）的地方，在纽约——我住纽约的时候——那对我来说太硬核了。人们都穿着皮背带、皮帽、狗项圈，打扮得非常彻底。而我呢，总想套件黑色开衫之类的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And a mock turtleneck. I thought, "I'll show you. I can do the scene." And I saw these two men. They were just so hardcore. And one had the other one on a leash. Nipples were pinched, and things were hanging in all kinds of apparatus I couldn't even identify. And so I inch close to them because I go, I want to hear what these two are talking about. And I inch behind them, and this guy said, "I just loved that angel cake. It was so moist. Can I have the recipe?" "Well, mother has it on a card. I will write mother and have her send it."
还穿件高领毛衣。我想，“让你们看看，我也能混圈子。” 我看到两个男人。他们太硬核了。一个人用绳子牵着另一个。乳头被捏着，身上挂着我甚至认不出用途的各种装置。我悄悄靠近他们，因为我想听听这俩在聊什么。我凑到他们身后，这人说：“我真爱那块天使蛋糕。太润了。能把食谱给我吗？” “噢，母亲有食谱卡。我会写信给母亲，让她寄过来。”
832-3160.
832-3160。
832-3160. 312-832-3160, the number to call. Pledge your support for Your Radio Playhouse , WBEZ's brand new, groovy Friday evening show. 312-832-3160.
832-3160。312-832-3160，拨打这个号码。认捐支持《你的广播剧场》，WBEZ 周五晚全新的精彩节目。312-832-3160。
Again, these are premia-- some of these-- that are only being offered tonight. Shirley, we'll check back with you in a couple minutes.
再说一次，这些赠品——有些——只在今晚提供。雪莉，几分钟后再找你。
Thanks, Ira.
谢谢，艾拉。
Call. Please call. Please call. We are trying to figure out stuff that you might enjoy, now as ever.
打电话。请一定要打电话。请一定要打电话。我们正在努力想出你们可能喜欢的素材。
Well, Act Three, Dave's Response. It's an odd thing, actually, as a reporter, calling a stranger on the phone and asking him to defend things he did 15 years before as a teenager. Who amongst us wants to get that call? So I reached Dave at his parents' house, where he still lives. And he's a devout Christian now. He writes and edits a Christian magazine for young people. And he says he's never been happier.
好了，第三幕：戴夫的回应。作为记者，给一个陌生人打电话，要求他为 15 年前青春期时做过的事辩护，这其实挺奇怪的。我们谁想接到那样的电话呢？所以我联系到了住在父母家的戴夫，他至今仍住在那里。他现在是一位虔诚的基督徒。他为年轻人撰写和编辑一本基督教杂志。他说他从未如此快乐。
No, he does not really think about Bob very often. No, Bob is not a big figure in his life. No, he does not remember the fight with Mike. Yes, he remembers being enemies with Bob in the seventh grade. But no, he wasn't sure why. The best that he could remember, Bob was to blame. Bob, by becoming friends with someone else.
不，他确实不常想起鲍勃。不，鲍勃在他生活中不是个重要人物。不，他不记得和迈克的那场架了。是的，他记得七年级时和鲍勃成了敌人。但不知道为什么。他能记起的最好说法是，鲍勃有错。鲍勃因为和别人成了朋友。
And they were doing these other things. I got really mad and everything, and it was like going from best friends to worst. I'm trying to remember this.
而且他们还在做其他那些事。我变得非常生气，一切就那样了，感觉从最好的朋友变成了最坏的敌人。我正在努力回忆这件事。
And he remembers-- is this also accurate or do you remember this as well? He remembers you turning other people against him. He says that at one point, there was actually a "I Hate [? Cooze ?] Club" that you started.
他还记得——这准确吗？还是你也记得？他记得你煽动其他人反对他。他说有一次，你甚至组建了一个“我恨 [? Cooze ?] 俱乐部”。
Oh, gosh. Again, I don't even remember that. But now that you say it, gosh, what a terrible person I must've been, because that's horrible. Oh, man, I actually kind of remember that now. That's pretty lame.
噢，天哪。真的，我不记得了。但你现在一提，天哪，我当时一定是个多糟糕的人啊，因为那太可怕了。噢，天哪，我其实确实有点想起来了。那太逊了。
What do you remember of it?
你记得什么吗？
I don't. That's just it. When you said the name, it's like, oh, my gosh, did I really do that? I have no idea.
我不记得了。就是这样。当你提到名字时，就像：噢，天哪，我真的做了那样的事吗？我完全不知道。
When he describes you during that period, he felt like you had a kind of David Koresh-like power over others.
当他描述你那段时期的表现时，他觉得你当时对其他人拥有那种大卫·考雷什般的力量。
Well, I mean, we were in high school. I'm trying to think of--
嗯，我是说，我们那时候在高中。我正试着想——
Can you imagine yourself being seen in that light?
你能想象自己被那样看待吗？
No, not really at all. Looking back now, I feel like I was always the one that was really, totally at the bottom of the social level, or whatever you want to call it, in school. And I'm thinking, I wonder what caused me to do something like that. Obviously, to make myself look better or something, because-- I don't know, but that's pretty bad.
不，一点也不。现在回过头看，我觉得我当时在学校里一直是在社交层面的最底层，或者随便你怎么叫。我在想，到底是什么导致我做出那种事。显然是为了让自己看起来更好什么的，因为——我不知道，但这真的很糟糕。
I'll tell you the way that Bob remembers and interprets what happened between the two of you. He doesn't remember it as being the kind of thing where he became friends with somebody else. He says that you guys were really, really close-- really close friends. And then, when everybody hit adolescence, a really typical thing happened to you, and that is that other boys started accusing you of being gay. And that you publicly wanted to put a stop to it.
我来告诉你鲍勃是怎么记忆和解读你们之间发生的事情的。他并不觉得是因为他结交了别人。他说你们当时关系非常、非常亲密。然后，当大家都进入青春期时，一件非常典型的事情发生在了你们身上，那就是其他男孩开始指责你们是同性恋。而你为了公开表明立场，想制止这种指责。
Gosh, honestly, I cannot even remember this. He has a much better memory than me. I know we were close and everything, but I don't ever remember any accusations like that. No. And I'm trying to think, too. I'm sitting here trying to drag it out of my memory as to why did we start fighting in the first place? And I'm thinking, but jeez.
天哪，说真的，我甚至完全想不起来了。他的记忆力比我好。我知道我们当时很亲密，但我完全不记得有那样的指责。没有。我还在试着想，我坐在这儿拼命搜寻记忆，到底我们为什么会打起来？我心想，天哪。
Actually, the thing that it's making me think about is, in the case of a story like this, I think it's easier for a person who was the injured person-- or believes they were the injured person-- to remember something than the person who did something hurtful. Because I think it's so much more embarrassing to remember yourself as being someone who did something hurtful.
其实这让我想到一点，像这样的故事，我觉得受伤的一方——或者认为自己是受害方的一方——更容易记得这些事，而不是做伤害行为的人。因为我觉得记住自己曾做过伤害人的事更令人难堪。
Right. Now I work with kids that are about that age. And they get in their little spats sometimes. And we just always go to the Bible together. And I try to say, well, look, this person's your friend. We just had an incident like this last week. This one girl, her friends, all of a sudden, just wouldn't talk to her. I felt really bad for this person because she's always one of the gang. I'm thinking, man, I've got to get a hold of her and see what's wrong and everything and get all these people back together, because this isn't good.
没错。我现在和那个年纪的孩子一起工作。他们有时会闹点小别扭。我们总是回到圣经中寻找答案。我总是尝试说：看，那个人是你的朋友。我们上周刚发生过类似的事情。有个女孩，她的朋友们突然就不理她了。我当时很为她难过，因为她一直是那个圈子的一员。我想：天哪，我得找她聊聊看看出了什么问题，然后把这些人都召集起来，因为这样可不好。
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
Hello?
喂？
Hi, is Bob there?
你好，鲍勃在吗？
This is Bob.
我是鲍勃。
So after I spoke with Dave, I called Bob. I guess you could figure that out for yourself, huh?
所以和戴夫谈完后，我给鲍勃打了电话。我想你自己也能猜到吧，哈？
You describe him going and whispering in people's ear, Iago-like, saying, go do this, go do that, walk up to Bob and say this to him, push him in the locker. And he remembers none of that.
你描述他当时像伊阿古一样在别人耳边细语，说：去干这个，去干那个，走到鲍勃面前说这个，把他推进储物柜。而他完全不记得了。
I remember that very clearly.
我记得非常清楚。
Well, he remembers none of it.
嗯，他完全不记得了。
I remember it very clearly. That is stuff that scarred me for years and years and years. And it's no surprise that I remember it and he doesn't.
我记得非常清楚。那是折磨我多年、多年、多年的事。我不奇怪我记得而他不记得。
Thinking about what happened to you, just thinking about it over the last few days, it's really made me think about what it means to love somebody. You know how when you love somebody, you're always more aware of what they do in the room than anybody else?
想想发生在你身上的事，在这过去几天里一直思考，这让我不得不思考“爱一个人”意味着什么。你知道当你爱一个人时，你总是比其他人更在意他在屋里的一举一动吗？
And because you guys really loved each other, anything that he would do in a room would be something that would be more apparent to you than what anybody else was doing and would seem more important. So if somebody else were just as influential over other kids in the class, you would always be more aware of what Dave did.
因为你们曾真心相爱，他在屋里做的任何事都会比别人做的事更引起你的注意，显得更重要。所以如果其他人对班上的学生也同样有影响力，你也会比别人更在意戴夫所做的事。
Yeah, I would say all of his activities were illuminated more to me than to anyone else because of that. But I do know that he was the focal point for all this antagonism against me throughout those years. No doubt. He generated it. It didn't just come from nowhere.
没错，我想他所有的活动在我眼中确实比在别人眼里更显眼，正是因为那个原因。但我确实知道，在那几年里，他就是所有针对我敌对活动的焦点。毫无疑问。是他制造了这一切。这并不是凭空发生的。
It's an odd thing to have a profound experience with somebody else, a really intimate experience, and you remember every detail. And the other person remembers none of it. And so you're left there alone. When I talked to Bob, I asked him about this over and over and over again because I thought it was such a particular kind of moment for him. But he didn't really take it that way.
和一个人的深层经历确实是很奇怪的，一段非常亲密的经历，你记得每一个细节。而对方却什么都不记得。于是你就只能独自留在那里。和鲍勃谈话时，我一遍又一遍地问他这件事，因为我觉得这对当时的他来说是一个极其特别的时刻。但他并不完全是那样看的。
I don't know, I have no reason to feel lonely about this. I don't expect Dave to remember it. What you're saying sounds like I should have animosity toward him because of what he did to me.
我不知道，我没理由在这件事上感到孤独。我不指望戴夫还记得。你说的听起来好像我因为他对我做过的事而对他怀恨在心似的。
No, I don't mean animosity at all. Actually, in fact, just the opposite. Simply someone else to confirm that it happened. That it happened and that it had a meaning.
不，我完全没提到怨恨。事实上，恰恰相反。只是需要有人来确认这件事确实发生过。发生过，并且它是有意义的。
Yeah. Yeah, you may be right. Now I feel alone. [LAUGHS] I mean, yeah, I can see myself saying, "But, Dave, don't you remember?" This was a massive event in my life.
是啊。是啊，你可能是对的。现在我感到孤独了。[笑] 我的意思是，是啊，我能想象自己说：“但是，戴夫，你不记得了吗？” 那是我生命中的重大事件。
As you were talking, I was thinking this is the Gabriel Garcia Marquez part of the story where, like, is memory lost? Does memory last? Does it mean anything if an entire nation forgets what it was? Or does it mean anything if we are the only one who remembers an experience and then we are lost, and so that experience is never remembered? Does it mean anything? And you're saying, really, no. Maybe it meant something to me, but no, not really.
当你说话时，我正在想这是加西亚·马尔克斯式的故事——记忆会消失吗？记忆会长存吗？如果一个国家彻底遗忘了它的过去，那还有意义吗？如果我是唯一记得这段经历的人，那我迷失了，这段经历就从未被记得吗？这有意义吗？你刚才在说，其实，没有。也许这对我来说有意义，但真的，没有意义。
And I can assure you that I am like-- I'm going to pronounce his name wrong, it's Jorge Luis Borges. Like he says, I'm remembering the last time I remembered it, which was a memory of the last time I remembered it, which is a memory of the last time I remembered it. It increasingly gets more and more dramatic, and the moment gets refined down to-- it gets distilled down into something which becomes very palatable and very understandable.
我可以向你保证，我就像——发音可能会错，是豪尔赫·路易斯·博尔赫斯。正如他所说，我是在记忆我最后一次记住它的时候，那是我最后一次记忆时的记忆，是我最后一次记忆时的记忆。它变得越来越戏剧化，那一刻被提炼，被精炼成某种变得非常可口和非常容易理解的东西。
One loose end in the whole thing, of course, was the friend, the mysterious friend. Remember, Dave said that Bob was to blame for them becoming enemies in the seventh grade by making friends with a guy who, we were told, is named Mike, though not the Mike whose wrist Bob later broke.
整件事里有一个悬念，当然，就是那个朋友，那个神秘朋友。还记得吗？戴夫说鲍勃要对他们七年级时反目成仇负责，因为鲍勃和一个家伙成了朋友，也就是我们提到的迈克，尽管他不是鲍勃后来弄断手腕的那个迈克。
I can sort of understand that. I know which Mike you're referring to, and I know that we did start to become friends then. But the friendship that I had with Dave was always the strongest friendship that I ever had up until probably five years ago when I met the person who I consider my best friend now. He always used to use the term "false friend" in seventh and eighth grade. I remember that clearly. He used to always say I was his "false friend."
我多少能理解。我知道你指的是哪个迈克，我也知道我们在那时开始成为了朋友。但在我遇到现在认为是最好的朋友之前的五年里，我和戴夫的友谊一直是我最深厚的。在七八年级时，他一直用“伪朋友”这个词。我记得很清楚。他总是说我是他的“伪朋友”。
Meaning what?
这是什么意思？
Well, what is it? I don't know. What does it mean? It means you were friends, but now it's fake or it's--
嗯，是什么意思呢？我不知道。那意味着什么？这意味着你们曾经是朋友，但现在是假的，或者……
See, to me, false friend means that he thinks that you betrayed him.
你看，对我来说，“伪朋友”意味着他认为你背叛了他。
Could be. It could be. God, wouldn't that be awful if it all boiled down to one event where he felt like me and Mike were becoming friends, and it could've been cleared up in one conversation?
可能是吧。可能是。天哪，如果这一切仅仅是因为某个瞬间，他觉得我和迈克成了朋友，而如果只要一场谈话就能解释清楚，那该有多糟糕。
That it was a complete misunderstanding.
那完全是一个误解。
That it was just a total tiny misunderstanding that could have been cleared up?
那完全是一个微不足道的误解，本来可以解释清楚的？
Happens all the time.
这种事经常发生。
Boy, I would just love to see what my life would have been like if that would have happened.
天哪，我真想看看如果当时解释清楚了，我的人生会是什么样。
In Act Four, another perspective on the whole thing from David Sedaris. But first, let's go to Pledge Central. Shirley Jahad.
在第四幕，戴维·塞达里斯关于整件事的另一个视角。但在那之前，让我们去认捐中心。雪莉·贾哈德。
Ira Glass.
艾拉·格拉斯。
Hi, honey.
你好，亲爱的。
Hi, sweetie.
你好，甜心。
I understand that we're having problems with the phones.
我想我们的电话系统出了点问题。
We have demons, demons on the pledge lines. Maybe Bob or somebody has infiltrated here. Anyway, the number is 312-832-3160. If you're having trouble getting through, please be patient and do not give up on us. 312-832-3160 to pledge your support for Your Radio Playhouse. on WBEZ Chicago. Now, I understand some people are calling and it's ringing, but we're not hearing it ring here. And eventually we do hear it ring, but that's after several minutes.
认捐热线受到了恶魔骚扰。也许是鲍勃或谁渗透进来了。总之，号码是 312-832-3160。如果你们打不进来，请保持耐心，不要放弃。312-832-3160，认捐支持 WBEZ 芝加哥的《你的广播剧场》。现在，我知道有些人打电话进来，铃声确实在响，但我们这边没听到。最终我们听到了，但那已经过了几分钟了。
So if you're having trouble getting through, and if you don't get through until the exact moment when our show ends, and you want some of the premia from this hour and the phones aren't working, ask for them and we'll give them to you.
所以，如果你很难打进来，如果你直到节目结束的那一刻才打通，而你又想要这一个小时里的一些赠品，即使电话坏了，尽管要，我们会给你的。
That's right. 312-832-3160.
没错。312-832-3160。
Here we go. Here's something we haven't played yet. Again, we have special premia. One is the Un-Cabaret CD. One is the Shut Up, Little Man CD, which maybe I'll just play a little clip of that real fast. It's a very odd CD-- these two guys who would fight all the time. And it's sort of audio verite recorded by their neighbors next door as these two men would scream at each other. Here we go.
好了。这里有我们还没放过的。再说一遍，我们有特别赠品。一个是“非歌舞表演”CD，一个是《闭嘴，小矮子》CD，也许我可以快速放一点点片段。那是一张很奇怪的 CD——这两个人总是吵架。这是邻居记录下的音频实录，这两个男人对着尖叫。开始吧。
--cut your toenails, so why would I worry about it? For god's sakes, shut up, little man. I don't want to watch you cut your toenails. I would liked to have eaten tonight also, but I can't because of you talking about toenails.
——剪你的脚趾甲，我为什么要担心？看在上帝的份上，闭嘴，小矮子。我不想看你剪脚趾甲。我本来也想吃晚饭的，但因为你一直叨叨脚趾甲，我吃不下。
Now, I should say the music in there is actually from our little mix that we did on the show. And this is one of those things that it's hard to get a sense of just in a brief little clip. Another thing we're giving away is recent work by beloved NPR commentator David Sedaris. And that includes work that he's done here on Your Radio Playhouse , that is, some of the radio plays he's done with his sister, Amy, and other actors. And this piece, this half-hour hitchhiking story that he told. Here's one little brief, brief episode from that story.
现在，我应该说里面的音乐其实是我们节目里做的混音。这是一些很难从简短片段中体会精髓的东西。我们送出的另一个赠品是备受喜爱的 NPR 评论员戴维·塞达里斯的近期作品。其中包括他在《你的广播剧场》中做的内容，也就是他和他妹妹艾米以及其他演员录制的广播剧。还有这篇，他讲述的那个半小时搭便车的故事。这是故事里的一小段摘录。
I got an interminable ride with a pantyhose salesman who spent six hours saying "You just take and take, don't you? Don't you? Out there with your thumb in the air, not a care in the world, grabbing whatever you can get. Yes, sir, you take and you take until you're ready to burst. But what about giving? Did you ever think about that? Of course not. You're too busy taking.
我搭上了一辆连绵不断的车，是个卖连裤袜的推销员，他花了六个小时说：“你只是索取和索取，对吧？不是吗？在那儿大拇指朝上，一点也不在乎这个世界，抓住你能得到的任何东西。没错，先生，你拿了又拿，直到准备爆掉。但给予呢？你想到过那个吗？当然没有。你太忙于索取了。”
Me, I'm what you call a taxpayer. Tax, it's a tariff that working people have to pay so that someone like you can enjoy a life of leisure. I give, and I give until I've got nothing left. Then I turn right around, and I give some more. I give and give to all of Uncle Sam's little takers. And I've been thinking that maybe it's about time I get a little something in return. Yes, indeed. Maybe it's time we try that shoe on the other foot for a change. You, my young friend, are going to wash my car, inside and out, and you're going to pay for it."
“我呢，我是所谓的纳税人。税收，是劳动人民必须缴纳的关税，好让像你这样的人能享受闲适的生活。我给予，我一直给予，直到一无所有。然后我回过头来，再给更多。我给予，给予山姆大叔的所有小索取者。我想也许是时候让我得到点回报了。没错。也许是时候让角色互换一下了。你，我年轻的朋友，你要去给我洗车，里里外外，而且你要自己付钱。”
Anyway, again, the number if you want this very odd collection of stories from David Sedaris, 832-3160. The collection includes the story that we're going to hear at the end of this evening's show.
不管怎样，再说一次，如果你想要这个来自戴维·塞达里斯的极其奇怪的故事集，拨打 832-3160。这个合集包含了我们今晚节目最后要听的故事。
312-832-3160. Call now to pledge your support for Your Radio Playhouse , a place where you hear David Sedaris' stories in their entirety, the uncut versions you will get on that cassette that you can get for a $60 pledge. 312-832-3160. Be patient, and let that phone ring, and we will get to you as soon as we can.
312-832-3160。现在就打电话认捐支持《你的广播剧场》，在这里你可以听到戴维·塞达里斯故事的完整未删减版，也就是你认捐 60 美元可以得到的磁带。312-832-3160。请耐心等待，让电话响，我们会尽快接听。
We put a lot of effort into this show to bring you unusual stories that you will not hear anywhere else. And we want your support. We want your support. And we were trying to find premia that you would enjoy and could get nowhere else. So please, please call. Please call and join our fun little party here. And I guess that's it. 832-3160.
为了给你们带来别处听不到的不寻常故事，我们在这档节目中付出了很多努力。我们想要你们的支持。我们想要你们的支持。我们试图寻找你们会喜欢且在别处找不到的赠品。所以请，请拨打电话。请拨打电话，加入我们这场有趣的派对。我想就是这样了。832-3160。
312-832-3160. And take it, Ira. I guess we'll go on.
312-832-3160。接下去吧，艾拉。我想我们要继续了。
Well, Act Four. Act Four of this evening's program is called Another Dave. And this story by David Sedaris, frequent Morning Edition commentator, member of the Pinetree Gang, contributor to this program. And this is a story of ultimate Machiavellian scheming. It's kind of an endpoint as to how far you can go. It's called "The Last Time You'll Ever Hear from Me." It's a story, and it's read by Sarah Thyre.
好了，第四幕。今晚节目的第四幕叫“另一个戴夫”。这个故事来自频繁出现在《早间版》的评论员、松树帮成员、本节目的贡献者戴维·塞达里斯。这是一个关于终极马基雅维利式阴谋的故事。这算是你可以走多远的一个终点。它叫《你最后一次听到我的消息》（The Last Time You'll Ever Hear from Me）。这是一个故事，由莎拉·泰尔朗读。
Dear friends and family, by the time you receive this letter, I will be dead. Those of you attending this service are sitting quietly holding a beautiful paperweight, a gift from the collection which, in life, had been my pride and joy. You turn the paperweight over in your hands, look deep inside at the object embedded in the glass, be it a rose or a scorpion, whatever. And through your tears, you ask, what is death like?
亲爱的朋友和家人，当我这封信传到你们手中时，我已经死了。那些参加追悼会的人正静静地坐着，手里拿着一个精美的镇纸，那是从我生前引以为傲的收藏品中挑选的一份礼物。你们在手中翻转着镇纸，注视着嵌入玻璃深处的物体，无论是玫瑰还是蝎子，随便什么。在泪水中，你们问，死亡是什么样的？
By this time, I certainly know the answer to that question, but I'm unable to give details. Know only that I will one day meet you upon the grassy plains of heaven where, with the exception of Randy Sykes and Annette Kelper, I will be tickled to embrace you and catch up on all the news.
到那时，我当然已经知道答案了，但我无法描述细节。只要知道，终有一天，我会去天堂的草地上迎接你们，在那里，除了兰迪·赛克斯和安妮特·凯尔珀之外，我会很高兴地拥抱你们，叙叙旧。
If my instructions were followed the way I wanted them to be-- see attached instruction envelope number one-- this letter is being read to you from the pulpit of the Simple Shepherd Church of Christ by my best friend, Eileen Mickey-- hi, Eileen-- who is wearing the long-sleeve Lisa Montino designer dress I left behind that always looked so good on me.
如果我的指示得到了执行——见附件一号指示信封——这封信现在正由我最好的朋友艾琳·米基从简朴牧羊人基督教会的讲坛上读给你们听——嘿，艾琳——她身上穿的是我留下的那件丽莎·蒙蒂诺长袖设计师连衣裙，那件穿在我身上一直很好看的裙子。
Eileen, I hope you either lost some weight or took it out some on the sides, or you're not going to be able to breathe. Also remember, it needs to be dry cleaned. I know how you and your family love to skimp. But please, don't listen to what anyone says about Woolite. Dry clean.
艾琳，我希望你要么瘦了点，要么把侧面改大了，不然你肯定穿不进去。还有记住，它需要干洗。我知道你和你家人有多喜欢省钱。但求你们，别听信任何人关于 Woolite 洗衣液的鬼话。干洗。
Most of you are probably wondering why I did it. You're whispering, "Why, Lord? Why take Trish Moody? Trish was a ray of bright sunshine, always so up and perky and full of love. Pretty, too. Just as smart and sweet and pretty as they come."
你们大多数人可能都在纳闷我为什么这么做。你们私语道：“为什么，上帝啊？为什么要带走翠西·穆迪？翠西是那样的阳光，总是那么乐观活泼，充满爱心。长得也漂亮。聪明、甜美、漂亮，无可挑剔。”
You're probably shaking your heads and thinking there's plenty of people a lot worse than Trish Moody. There's her former excuse for a boyfriend, Randy Sykes, for example. The boyfriend who, after Trish accidentally backed her car over his dog, practically beat her senseless. He beat her with words, but still, it might as well have been with his fists. He struck her again and again with words and names such as "manipulative," "jealous," "childish," and others I wouldn't justify in print. The dog's death was a tragic accident, but perhaps also a blessing in disguise, as Randy tended to spend entirely too much time with it.
你们可能摇着头觉得翠西·穆迪远不是最坏的人。比如说她以前那个叫兰迪·赛克斯的前男友。那个翠西不小心开车压死他的狗后，几乎把她打得半死的男朋友。他是用语言打的，但就算那样，也和拳头没两样。他用“操纵”、“嫉妒”、“幼稚”等词汇反复抨击她，这些词我甚至不屑写出来。那只狗的死是一场悲剧，但也许是一种因祸得福，因为兰迪花在它身上的时间实在是太多了。
What did Trish's mother say when her daughter, heartbroken over her breakup with Randy, came to her in search of love and understanding? If you're looking for sympathy, you can find it between "sob story" and "syphilis" in the dictionary. Perhaps my mother can live with slogans such as this. I know I can't.
当她的女儿翠西因为和兰迪分手伤心欲绝，向她寻求爱和理解时，翠西的母亲说了什么？“如果你想找同情，字典里‘苦情故事’（sob story）和‘梅毒’（syphilis）中间有的是。” 也许我妈能靠这种口号生活，但我不能。
Neither can I live surrounded by friends such as Annette Kelper. Poor, chubby Annette Kelper, who desperately tries to pretend that nobody notices the fact that she's balding on top of her head. That's right. Look closely. Balding, just like a man.
我也不能忍受生活在像安妮特·凯尔珀这样的朋友身边。可怜、臃肿的安妮特·凯尔珀，她极力装作没人注意到她头顶正在秃顶的事实。没错，仔细看。秃顶，就像个男人一样。
Perhaps Randy feels sorry for chrome-dome Annette. Maybe that's why he was seen twice in her company in a single five-day period. Seen standing together in the parking lot of the Burger Tabernacle-- her home away from home-- and seen huddled together, laughing on the escalator of the Crabtree Valley Mall. Annette, my supposed best friend, who secretly wanted and coveted everything I owned. Is everyone on earth as two-faced as Annette Kelper? Is everyone as cruel as Randy Sykes? I think not.
也许兰迪同情秃头安妮特。也许这就是为什么他在五天内两次被看见和她在一起。被看见一起站在“汉堡会幕”（Burger Tabernacle）的停车场——她的第二个家——还被看见在螃蟹谷商场的自动扶梯上缩在一起大笑。安妮特，我那所谓的最好的朋友，暗中想要并觊觎我拥有的一切。世上每个人都像安妮特·凯尔珀一样虚伪吗？每个人都像兰迪·赛克斯一样残忍吗？我不觉得。
Most of you, the loved ones I left behind, are simple, devoted people. I urge you now to take a look around the room. Are Randy Sykes and Annette sitting in the audience? Are they shifting uncomfortably in the pew, shielding their faces with the 8 and 1/2 by 11 photograph of me I had reproduced to serve as a memento of this occasion?
你们大多数人，我留下的亲人，都是单纯、忠诚的人。我请求你们现在环顾四周。兰迪·赛克斯和安妮特在观众席里吗？他们是不是坐在长椅上局促不安，用我为了这个场合制作的 8.5 x 11 大照片遮着脸？
Eileen, read this part real fast before they have a chance to leave. Randy Sykes' drip is the size of my little finger, and that's when it's hard. And I'm not counting the nail-- just the finger. He had sex two times with a boy at Camp Ticonderoga when he was in junior high school. Maybe that explains why he loves it with somebody sticks their finger up his [? couvade. ?] He used to beg me to do that, but I refused. I said, "No way, Randy." He used to do it to himself all the time. That's why I never held hands with him. His hands stink.
艾琳，快读这一段，别让他们有机会离开。兰迪·赛克斯的小弟弟只有我的小指头那么大，而且是在硬起来的时候。而且我还没算指甲——就只算手指。他在初中时曾在蒂康德罗加营地和男孩发生过两次性行为。也许这就解释了为什么他喜欢别人把手指插进他的 [? couvade ?] 里。他过去常求我那么做，但我拒绝了。我说：“没门，兰迪。” 他自己老那么做。这就是为什么我从不牵他的手。他的手臭死了。
He secretly thinks he looks like Marlon Brando, but take a good look. A young Marlin Perkins is more like it. Maybe that's what he sees in Annette Kelper. He's an animal lover. She used to come to my house crying. Her breath smelled a mile off, like her uncle's drip. She said he forced her, but that's a lie, because you don't force whores. And that's what she is, a whore.
他私下里觉得他长得像马龙·白兰度，但请仔细看看。更像年轻时的马林·珀金斯。也许这就是他在安妮特·凯尔珀身上看到的。他是个动物爱好者。她曾到我家哭诉。她的口臭隔一里地都能闻到，像她叔叔的口臭一样。她说他是强迫她的，那是谎话，因为你不会强迫妓女。而她就是个妓女。
Annette and Randy deserve each other. Drip-Breath and Stinky-Finger, riding up and down the escalator at Crabtree Valley, up and down, up and down. Fancy little shuck-cutlets. Look at them. Take a good, hard look at them. It's their fault I'm dead. They are to blame.
安妮特和兰迪天生一对。口臭和臭手，在螃蟹谷的扶梯上上下下，上上下下。这两个时髦的小贱人。看看他们。好好地、狠狠地看看他们。我死了是他们的错。他们才是该受谴责的人。
I urge you now to take those paperweights and stone them. Release your anger. The Bible says it's all right to cast the first stone if someone dead is telling you do it. And I'm telling you now. Pretend the paperweights are stones and cast them upon the guilty. I put aside my savings to pay for the damages to the walls and windows. It's money I was saving for my wedding, and there's plenty of it. So throw. Hurt them the way they hurt me. Kill them! Nobody will hold you responsible. Kill them!
我请求你们现在拿起那些镇纸，砸向他们。释放你们的怒火吧。圣经说，如果死人叫你砸，你可以扔出第一块石头。我现在就在叫你们扔。把镇纸想象成石头，砸向那些罪人。我存了钱赔偿墙壁和窗户的损失。那是原本留给我结婚用的钱，多的是。所以扔吧。像他们伤害我一样伤害他们。杀了他们！没人会追究你们。杀了他们！
Eileen, I'm going to allow a few minutes here because it might take a while for certain people to get into the swing of it. Pop in the cassette marked "Stoning," and wait until both Randy and Annette are lifeless. Wait until everyone is finished with their paperweights. And then I want you to hand the microphone over to my mother. Watch the way she trembles and stutters, and remember every gesture as if you were me.
艾琳，我会留几分钟，因为某些人可能需要一点时间进入状态。放上标记着“乱石”的磁带，等着兰迪和安妮特都没了气息。等大家用完镇纸。然后我要你把话筒交给我的母亲。看着她颤抖和结巴的样子，记住每一个动作，就像你就是我。
832-3160. Shirley Jahad? Well, I guess you're not there.
832-3160。雪莉·贾哈德？好吧，我想你不在了。
I'm here, Ira.
我在这儿，艾拉。
You are?
你在？
You know, our volunteers are so resourceful.
你知道，我们的志愿者太聪明了。
And are they getting phone calls in?
他们在接电话吗？
They are taking your phone calls now. 312-832-3160.
他们正在接你们的电话。312-832-3160。
OK, you can get that story, which was from David Sedaris' book Barrel Fever , read by Sarah Thyre, plus also lots of other David Sedaris work, a 90-minute cassette full of all sorts of stuff.
好吧，你可以得到那个故事，来自戴维·塞达里斯的《桶热》（Barrel Fever），莎拉·泰尔朗读，加上许多其他戴维·塞达里斯的作品，一盘 90 分钟的磁带，装满了各种素材。
For just $60. 312-832-3160.
只需 60 美元。312-832-3160。
Or the two CDs that we've been plugging all hour. I should also mention that David is going to be here in Chicago, live this coming Saturday night at the Park West for Milly's Orchid Show. You might want to go see him there.
或者我们整个小时都在宣传的两张 CD。我还得说，戴维这周六晚将亲临芝加哥，在公园西剧场参加“米莉的兰花秀”。你们可能想去看看他。
Cool.
太棒了。
Yeah.
是啊。
312-832-3160. Call now and what, Ira?
312-832-3160。现在打电话，然后呢，艾拉？
And pledge your support. Remember, this is the only time you're going to get during the drive to get most of these premia and super size it.
认捐支持。记住，这是你在筹款期间能获得大部分赠品并“超值升级”的唯一机会。
Super size it.
“超值升级”。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[节目资金来源声明]
Today's program was produced by Peter Clowney and myself with Dolores Wilber, Alix Spiegel, and Nancy Updike, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Paul Tough. Paul Tough did the fabulous original interview with Bob featured in the first half of this program. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia.
今天的节目由彼得·克劳尼和我自己制作，多洛雷斯·威尔伯、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普戴克协助，杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和保罗·塔夫担任特约编辑。保罗·塔夫进行了节目上半部分那个关于鲍勃的精彩采访。WBEZ 管理层监管由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a tape of this or other Playhouse shows, call us at WBEZ, 832-3380, or email us, [email protected] . We broadcast proudly from WBEZ Chicago. We'll be back next week with more stories of This American Life. See you then.
欲购买本期或其他剧场的磁带，请拨打 WBEZ：832-3380，或电邮至 [email protected] 。我们从芝加哥 WBEZ 自豪地播出。下周我们将带着更多《美国生活》（This American Life）的故事回归。到时候见。